function g can be thought of as a
stretched or compressed version of f of
x is equal to the absolute value of x
what is the equation for g of x so you
can see f of x is equal to the absolute
value of x here in blue and then g of x
not only does it look stretched or
compressed but it also is flipped over
the x-axis so like always pause this
video and see if you can come up
yourself with the equation for g of x
all right now let's work through this
together
so there's a couple of ways we could do
it we could first try to flip f x and
then try to stretch or compress it or we
could stretch or compress it first and
then try to flip it let's actually let's
flip it first so let's say that we have
a function that looks like this it's
just exactly what f of x is but flipped
over the x-axis
so let's just flip over the x-axis so
all the values
for any given x whatever y you used to
get you're now getting the negative of
that
so this graph right over here this would
be the graph i'll call this y
is equal to
the negative absolute value of x
whatever the absolute value of x would
have gotten you before you're now going
to get the negative or the opposite of
it so this is getting us closer to our
definition of g of x the key here is how
do we appropriately stretch or squeeze
this green function
so let's think about what's happening on
this green function when x is equal to
one
the function itself is equal to negative
but we want it if we want it to be the
same as g we want it to be equal to
negative four so it's actually four
times the value for given x at least for
x equals one g is giving me something
four times the value that my green
function is giving it's not just the
true for positive x's it's also true for
negative x's you can see it right over
here when x is equal to
negative 1 my green function gives me
negative 1 but g
gives me negative 4. so it's giving me 4
times the values give me 4 times a
negative value so it's going even more
negative so you can see to go from the
green to g you have to multiply
this thing right over here
by 4.
so that is what essentially stretches it
down stretches it down in the vertical
direction so we could say that g of x
is equal to
it's not negative absolute value of x
negative 4
times the absolute value of x and you
could have done it the other way you
could say hey let's com let's first
stretch or compress f and say all right
before we even flip it over if we were
to unflip g it would look like this
if we were on flip g
it would look
it would look like
it would look like this
if we were to unflip g
so this thing right over here this thing
looks like 4 times f of x we could write
this as
we could write this as
y is equal to 4
times f of x or you could say y is equal
to 4 times
the absolute value of x and then we have
a negative sign whatever you have
whatever positive value you're getting
before you now get the opposite value
and that would flip it over and get you
to g which is exactly what we already
got